well it's the first of the year a lot of
people do this silly thing called
resolutions new year's resolutions the
problem with new year's resolutions for
most people is is they fall more in the
category of wish I wish I could I wish
for 2019 I don't want you to wish I want
you to do it so I'm going to suggest
that you substitute the word resolutions
for goals what are you going to do not
what are you going to talk about and
wish about what are you going to do
differently in 2019 so that you have a
more abundant better life because it is
up to you you're not gonna win the
lottery you're not gonna wake up one
morning suddenly 50 pounds lighter
you're not going to dot dot dot become
wealthy what in one day in one week in
one month it's not going to happen so
you're going to have to begin to take
the steps of intentionality and that's
called setting goals and then asking
yourself about those goals what has to
be true that is not true now in my life
to hit those goals now around here we
teach goal-setting this time of year for
our team and for our business units we
ask them what do you want it what do you
want your desired future to be what
would you like your future to look like
and then what do you have to do
differently to hit that future to cause
that future to be real because you are
the one that's gonna make it a reality
you should set goals really in about six
or seven areas you should have financial
goals obviously intellectual goals what
are you gonna read take a class family
goals spiritual goals I'm gonna read
through Scripture this year read
through the Bible here there's an app
with my friends over at U version help
you do that they've got to read through
the Bible in a year plan there's a lot
of those plans out there maybe you're
going to start attending church for the
first time or again physical goals
you're gonna lose weight get in better
shape run a marathon career goals gonna
change jobs get a better job make more
money find a job you love instead of
working on people you hate social goals
you're going to be a friend this year
like never before
so you set goals in these seven areas
and it changes everything
now goals are just wishes unless you put
some details to them I want to write a
book someday you won't I want to lose
weight you won't it's not enough detail
for a goal to work it must have five
components the first two are it must be
specific and it must be measurable I
want to lose weight is not specific it
is measurable I want to write a book is
specific then it is measurable so you've
got the first two done with that I want
to make more money that's that's not
specific but it is measurable and so you
have to make it specific how much more
money do you want to earn how much
weight do you want to lose I want to pay
off my debt good how much is your debt
that's specific and measurable I'm gonna
pal $36,000 in debt good very specific
very measurable the third one makes all
other math come together instantaneously
and your 6th grade math class kicks in
you can't keep long division from
occurring and that's when you put a time
limit on it
I want to lose 30 pounds great how many
times in over how many years I want to
make $100,000 win over the next 15 years
of the next 15 months or the next eight
months I don't know so when you give it
a time limit though it's instantaneous I
want to make a hundred thousand dollars
in the coming 12 months oh that's eighty
three hundred and thirty three dollars a
month that's $2,100 a week and if you're
on Commission we're going to get about
that because
if you're working overtime you're gonna
get about that business because you're
not gonna hit that goal if you don't
have rich $2,100 a week that's what gets
you to $100,000
you wanna lose 30 pounds great win the
next 90 days can you do that math with
me that's ten pounds a month to a nap
pounds a week increase your water intake
decrease your carbon so sugar intake
sweat 30 minutes a day doing something
and you will drop that weight that will
occur you don't even need Oprah see I
just did it for you that's how you do it
you put a time limit on it it's specific
and it's measurable the last two are
very very important and these are the
two that people mess up
number four is your goals for them to
work must be in writing you need to
write it down you can type it out you
can handwrite it I don't care what it is
but until it's written down it's not a
goal the Bible says make the V write the
vision and make it plain Habakkuk 2 to
write the vision and make it plain write
it down if you've got a goal for your
team with your team a desired future for
one of our business units here we put it
on the wall where everyone can see it
and then we all know if we won the
Superbowl or not did we hit the goal did
we ring the bell did we hit the mark we
know what the mark is and that way you
know if you hit it or not and it's in
writing and it's on display by the way
put it on display tell people in your
life that you will be embarrassed that
way if you don't do it and you don't
necessarily have to buy a billboard on
the side of the interstate but tell your
spouse tell some of your co-workers this
is what I'm doing tell some of your best
friends this is what I'm gonna do this
year this is what I'm going to do this
year and then if you don't do it they
can they can jazz you about it and razz
you about it that's a good thing too a
little bit of that accountability that's
called in the offing is good for you in
writing and broadcast it a little bit
specific measurable have a time limit
and in writing number five your goals
that are going to work must be your
goals my wife wants me to lose weight
you won't my husband wants me to make
more money
you won't my mother always wanted me to
be a dentist
I don't want to go to you you hurt
people because you're not there because
you are there as a healer you're there
to please your mommy other people's
goals when you're living other people's
life for them that is a miserable life
for you it's a miserable life for those
around you and you generally are
ineffective unproductive and don't it
doesn't happen by the way leaders when
you set goals for other people those
aren't goals those are called quotas so
you sit with your salesperson and you
help them develop their goals that fit
into the company goals the department
goals that's fine but - come on from on
high out of the ivory tower and make an
announcement the corporate says we're
going to sell X that's not a goal that's
a quota and that's demotivating instead
of motivating goals that work must be
specific they must be measurable they
must have a time limit and they must be
your goals not your mama's financial
intellectual family spiritual physical
career and social goals all right boys
and girls it's time to have a great 2019
I'm ready are you